from stockholm
to berlin
tokyo
[Music]
and
beirut
this is the anger over russia's invasion
of ukraine around the world
in london a crowd outside the prime
minister's downing street residence
making its demand loud and clear calling
for a complete economic isolation of
russia
and the worry that many here have for
their families back home
i was shocked my mom called me
it was five o'clock 4 30 in the morning
here and what's up and she was like
russians attacked
they really did
we are watching minute by minute what's
happening there
and lots of them are not safe
while prime minister boris johnson has
said that unprecedented measures have
been prepared to punish russia many here
feel that it is too little too late and
while the rest of the world may be
shocked at the invasion of ukraine
many ukrainians living abroad on art
in france home to some 30 000 ukrainians
hundreds gathered outside the russian
embassy in paris
singing
others shouted for an end to the
invasion
and many more gathered elsewhere in the
city all condemning the assault
but like many others around the world
determined to show their solidarity with
ukraine
sony gallego al jazeera london